we're going to get to work immediately
for the american people
and we're going to be doing a job
that hopefully you'll be so proud of
your president
you'll be so proud there's no doubt that
the result
in the 2016 presidential election was a
surprise
at least if you were setting your
expectations based on the polls
in 2016 polls in battleground states
showed then-candidate donald trump
trailing hillary clinton ahead of the
election look at that that's the
michigan voters
yeah she's ahead by seven pennsylvania
is
also looking like clinton country she's
up eight points the latest poll numbers
show hillary clinton
leading donald trump among wisconsin
voters after narrowly winning those
states four years ago
state surveys this year show president
trump is trailing again in key
battlegrounds
the president is also lagging behind the
democratic nominee in national polls
a recent wall street journal nbc news
poll showed joe biden ahead of the
president 53
to 42 percent so some voters are left
wondering how accurate are the polls
this year
you know most of the pulses are corrupt
as far as i'm concerned
if we believed in posters we wouldn't be
here right now
so what happened four years ago an
evaluation of 2016 polling
found that national polls were generally
accurate pew research center's courtney
kennedy who chaired the report says
that report in combination with
subsequent analysis of data
shows that there were issues with
state-level polling including a late
move towards trump among undecided
voters in some swing states which
earlier polls missed
a technical error in which pollsters
didn't wait their surveys accurately
so they weren't representative of the
populations they were trying to measure
and unexpectedly high turnout among
rural voters who previously weren't
likely to vote
these are some of the lessons pollsters
have had to reckon with as they work to
accurately
capture the mood of the electorate in
2020 ideally a poll starts with a random
sample
from everybody in the state or everybody
in in the country and that's important
because i mean it literally means that
everyone had a chance of selection
and it means that the people you sample
will
will be representative of everybody in
the state or everybody in the country
but cell phones have made building that
random sample harder
and more expensive if you go back number
of years
almost everybody had a landline phone
and when you called
someone would pick it up a pew research
center study looking at response rates
to their telephone surveys
showed that in the late 90s 36 percent
of people who were called
agreed to participate by 2018 that
number had dropped to 6 percent
the shift to cell phones brings an added
cost that's because pollsters can use
auto dialers for landlines
but not for cell phone numbers which
means the person conducting the poll has
to manually dial each number
these factors have given rise to new and
different types of polls
everybody wants to do interviewing
online right because that's much more in
touch with just where society is at in
people's lifestyles
but there is no way to draw a random
sample
of americans online a pollster will put
up an ad online
and invite people to come in now that's
not a random sample anymore by
definition you're excluding people
who aren't on the internet or might not
be on facebook
or a shopping website when you're
putting up your ad to solicit them
so not everyone in the country has an
equal chance to be in your poll
that means that your sample does not
necessarily reflect
the public and the world as it really is
to account for this
some pollsters use a process called
waiting which means they adjust the
survey sample to match characteristics
of the population they're trying to
survey
let's say there are not enough hispanic
women in the sample
anyone who's a hispanic woman who
answered the poll might
count for maybe 1.2 voices
in the poll rather than one if there are
too many college educated men
those people might count for 0.9 voices
in the poll
instead of one voice in the poll and in
that way
pollsters take their sample and adjust
adjusted to reflect
what they think the world really looks
like in 2016
many pollsters were slow to catch on to
key shifts in the electorate
like the degree to which educational
attainment was becoming a determining
factor in how someone might vote
that led pollsters in battleground
states to draw samples that did not
match the true makeup of the voter pool
the fact that america has become so much
more polarized
among gender lines and along the lines
of education
has consequences for polling uh two
groups in particular
are worth looking at one is white men
who don't have a college degree often
called white working class
men and then let's consider white women
with a college
degree these two groups have always been
different in their political
preferences as far back as our polling
goes but the differences were not that
great
but then in about 2010 these two groups
exploded apart and really their
preferences
on who they wanted to vote for really
changed when you have
people separated that much you
need to be sure that you're measuring
education accurately
kennedy says that in this election cycle
the three challenges from 2016 are still
in play
but to a lesser degree undecided voters
breaking
um you know in a strong numbers for one
candidate late
that could happen this year but what we
do know what's very clear
is that there's just fewer people in
that bucket and in terms of that
technical issue
of waiting by education the good news is
that
many state pollsters who had not been
doing that have fixed
their methods since 2016 and added
a waiting adjustment for education to
their polls so that's good
but not everybody has some posters still
refuse to do that and some posters
unfortunately still just
refuse to you know disclose how they do
their polling at all
and the third factor of of differential
turnout i would expect that posters will
have a better handle on that this time
it certainly would not come as any
surprise right if trump
uh repeats his success turning out the
rural vote
we say that a poll is a snapshot in time
it's what's happening
right now at the time we take the poll
but there's no way around the fact that
people look to these polls
as an indicator of what's going to
happen who's going to win
and they project forward but a poll
can't tell you for sure
who's going to vote we can only tell you
what people are saying now
and as the electorate changes and as
their preferences change
calling needs to make sure that it's up
to the moment
in accounting for what's changing in the
[Music]
electorate